ja und über den künftigen umgang der
europäischen union mit dem neuen regime
in afghanistan wollen wir sprechen mit
reinhard bütikofer sprecher der grünen
im europaparlament und mitglied im
ausschuss für auswärtige angelegenheiten
herr bütikofer ich grüße sie zunächst
erst mal nach brüssel die grünen haben
ja unter gerhard schröder den
afghanistan-einsatz mit beschlossen das
fazit jetzt millionen afghanen sind auf
der flucht vor den taliban es gibt
allein 60 tote bundeswehrsoldaten zu
beklagen es gibt viele milliarden die in
den zwei letzten jahrzehnten versichert
sind veruntreut worden wäre es nicht
vielleicht besser gewesen man wäre gar
nicht erst nach afghanistan reingegangen
also diese kurzformel kann man 20 jahre
einfach nicht bringen ich glaube es war
richtig
damals
solidarität zu zeigen gegenüber den
vereinigten staaten die in brutalster
weise
terroristisch angegriffen worden waren
ich glaube die internationale
gemeinschaft kann dem terrorismus nicht
einfach gleichgültig
gegenüber treten
dass dann aber über 20 jahre
sich eine dynamik entfaltet hat oder
genauer gesagt dass wir zugelassen haben
dass sich eine dynamik entfaltet die mit
dem desaster des truppenabzugs vor
kurzem enden musste das lag nicht von
vornherein in der intervention angelegt
und ich glaube die fehler die da gemacht
worden sind die wird man genau
analysieren müssen aber man sollte nicht
jetzt zum general urteilen
eilen die unhistorisch sind und die gar
nicht hinschauen wollen sondern die
eigentlich nur zum ausdruck bringen das
ist alles so schlimm wir wollen damit
nichts zu tun haben am besten hätten
wird damit nicht zu tun aber so geht das
nicht ja herr bütikofer nun kann man mal
direkt zur eu sind sehr viele menschen
auf der flucht aus afghanistan auf alle
fälle sind millionen wie kann wie wird
die europäische union da helfen also man
konnte sich bisher noch nicht mal auf
bestimmte kontingente einigen die man
aufnimmt
leider haben sie an dem punkt recht die
innenminister der europäischen union
haben sich auf eine flüchtlings abwehr
mentalität geeinigt es ist davon die
rede man wolle eine
migrations krise vermeiden in
wirklichkeit ist die krise längst da und
es handelt sich auch wenn man es
wirklich nüchtern betrachtet nicht um
eine migrationsbewegung sondern schlicht
um die flucht von vielen menschen wie
sie sagen die um leib und leben fürchten
innerhalb afghanistans sind so hört man
ungefähr drei millionen auf der flucht
mindestens zwei millionen haben
einstweilen den weg in eine relative
sicherheit im nachbarländer gefunden und
da hat die eu keine verantwortung ich
glaube die verantwortung ist dreifach
zum einen müssen wir wege suchen wie wir
humanitäre hilfe auch weiterhin leisten
können für die menschen in afghanistan
die diese dringend brauchen der
uno-generalsekretär hat an diese
notwendigkeit vor kurzem noch mal sehr
eindringlich erinnert zweitens sollten
wir auch uns angelegen sein lassen den
nachbarländern
afghanistans zu helfen die zu
unterstützen zu einer stabilisierung der
situation beizutragen und drittens bin
ich felsenfest überzeugt wir brauchen
eine internationale humanitäre konferenz
zu afghanistan
bei der so wie man als
1979 zum beispiel für die sogenannten
boatpeople aus vietnam gemacht hat auch
eine verabredung
offen wird zwischen den ländern die dazu
bereit sind bestimmte resettlement
quoten auch zu akzeptieren
herr bütikofer wie wird denn die eu
jetzt mit dem regime der taliban in
kabul umgehen dass man redet ist klar
aber ohne das geld des westens dürfte es
ja auch für die taliban ziemlich
schwierig werden
die europäische union hat sich auf
die haltung zunächst einmal verständigt
dass man den umgang vom konkreten
tun der neuen machthaber in afghanistan
abhängig machen will ganz sicher werden
wir die finanzielle unterstützung der
regierung in kabul nicht weiter führen
aber
die bereitschaft
konkret den menschen vor ort zu helfen
die ist nach wie vor gegeben wenn das
denn mit vernünftigen bedingungen
geschehen kann eine anerkennung eine
formelle anerkennung der taliban steht
überhaupt nicht zur debatte derzeit aber
man kann nun mal nicht
daran vorbei dass sie diejenigen sind
die in afghanistan jetzt die entwicklung
bestimmen und wenn man den menschen
helfen will dann muss man im zweifel
auch mit sehr unangenehmen partnern
reden ja nun wird er in der eu noch ganz
aktuell über die militärische
eingreiftruppe diskutiert die in krisen
intervenieren soll gerade haben wir doch
aber gesehen dass es nichts bringt wenn
man mit einem militäreinsatz versucht
einem land unsere westlichen werte
überstülpen zu wollen
ich glaube da werfen sie jetzt einiges
durcheinander entschuldigung aber
worüber wir diskutieren
ist etwas ganz anderes als hier setzt
darstellen wir müssen darüber
diskutieren dass es
unakzeptabel ist dass die eu noch nicht
mal in der lage ist einen flughafen
solange militärisch zu sichern
bis eine humanitäre
evakuierungsaktion abgeschlossen ist die
eu hat seit vielen jahren battlegroups
die eigentlich für solche fälle gedacht
sind die noch nie eingesetzt worden sind
die eu hat strukturen mit denen man
solche
aktionen
managen und leiten könnte die eu hat
einen operation headquarters
eingerichtet eigentlich sind die
voraussetzungen gegeben dass eine solche
begrenzte
aktion im humanitären sinne möglich sein
sollte dass es nicht stattgefunden hat
das noch nicht mal bei der koordinierung
der evakuierungsübung die
eu-mitgliedsländer gemeinsam gehandelt
haben sondern jeder vor sich hin
gewerkelt hat das ist glaube ich etwas
was wir nicht achselzuckend zur kenntnis
nehmen können und wo wir tatsächlich
etwas ändern müssen sie unterstellen es
ging dabei um die konzipierung von groß
angelegten
militärinterventionen weltweit das ist
völlig absurd ich bedanke mich für diese
einschätzungen bei reinhard bütikofer
nach brüssel